[Musique]
mais sa taille
ces clichés
le doux son des ferrari mercedes et
autres mclaren de la formule 1 résonnera
de nouveau à montréal en fin de semaine
le grand prix du canada est de retour
après deux ans d'arrêt forcé avec nous
ce soir françois du monde dumontier
pardon pdg du grand prix du canada
bonsoir monsieur dumont c'est merci
d'être avec nous ce soir pour parler de
cet événement qu'on relance est-ce que
c'est complexe de relancer un événement
qui est à l'arrêt quand même depuis deux
ans au complexe le champion du monde de
f1 malgré la pandémie continue
d'ailleurs les fin on doit le notre
chapeau parce que durant la bonhomie
plusieurs sports qui ont arrêté les
frais de port et et ils ont parcouru le
monde entier c'est un champion du monde
il avait un plan qu'ovide de très très
robuste et donc ils ont pu quand même
continuer à courir pour nous sauf un
c'est encore en même temps de les voir
courir sans néanmoins mais devrait
lancer non j'ai la chance d'avoir la
même équipe qui est en place avec moi
2019 une équipe d'expérience avec alors
donc on n'était pas trop y est dans les
faits est pris à défaut de week-end est
ce que le grand prix a été un risque un
certain moment de ne plus revenir à
montréal compte tenu que ça ne
fonctionnait pas pour montréal avec la
comédie non non du tout jamais en
dessous n'ont jamais parce que montréal
- une place importante dans le joueur du
monde de f1 on est le plus vieux grand
prix à l'extérieur du continent européen
on est à montréal depuis 1978 les
pilotes adorent
montréal c'est puis extrêmement
difficile pour les pilotes mais
l'ambiance la ville
en fait de la combinaison circuit ville
est très apprécié mais non au contraire
les deux années qu'on a manqué on doit
ajouter au contraire qui était valide
donc le montre maintenant et jusqu'en
2031 est ce que vous avez perdu de
l'argent et vous avez perdu combien
d'argent depuis deux ans
polian a pris c'est ce qu'on va un peu
de sous mais je me gardais de le montant
qu'on a pu quand le podium mais mais est
ce que quand on a perdu je n'ai pas
annulé gratuit au tout début à mars
on a remis on a cédé 9 en octobre donc
on a travaillé en fonction d'être 2021 c
est essentiellement même chose
malheureusement on n'a pas pu la
propulser 10 et des pertes économiques
importantes quand on parle du grand prix
on dit toujours que le grand prix c'est
à peu près le plus gros événement
touristique si je me trompe pas
d'évènement sportif et touristique le
plus important et au grade et donc ça
représente quoi en retombées économiques
la danse de tout ce qu'on a fait à
présent plus 2019 représenter environ le
pour le produit intérieur brut environ
64 millions de dollars il a deux
dernières études qu'on avait fait
auparavant en 2015 était à 42 millions
est venu à 2019 a eu beaucoup plus de
spectateurs en ville et ce qui est
intéressant avec le scrutin on dit plus
important événement sportif et
touristique
avant la pandémie 54% nos clients
étaient de l'extérieur du québec et post
pandémie on est à 57 % de notre
clientèle qui nous provient de
l'extérieur du québec comment vous
l'expliquez ces sites il expliqué parce
que au moment où on a mis les biens en
vente les restrictions de voyage était
encore très présente donc bon il demande
à des gens qui ont un cachet libyen en
2020 qu'ils ont conservé pour dénigrer
t1 et qu'ils ont remportée en 2022 mais
je prends quand même qu'il ya beaucoup
de mire 15
d'européens évidemment de les enterrer
les cadres qui vont y participer combien
ça coûte faire un grand prix
ça coûte cher ça coûte cher évidemment
il ya les droits pour le programme pour
avoir la course à montréal et puis on
était un circuit temporaire c'était très
difficile de pouvoir comparer avec
d'autres dogon puis dans le monde parce
que la majeure partie des circuits sont
permanents donc ils ont plusieurs
épreuves durant l'année point la formule
avait d'autres d'autres types de courses
dans notre circuit sans raison par année
il est temporaire on doit monter
démonter les les tribunes à chaque fois
donc on peut imaginer que c'est quand
même une somme importante
j'aurais pas la somme exacte mais quelle
est la part du de l'argent privé et de
l'argent public dans l'organisation du
grand prix l'argent public qui connut le
savions au tour d'une hauteur de 20
millions de dollars de contributions qui
sont voisines ne vient pas
l'organisateur mais votre directement
dans les poches de franchiseurs
dans notre comme on va mettre un autre
je vois jouer entre 20 et 25 millions $
ok donc ça nous donne un peu une idée de
ce musée a organisé un grand oui c'est
quand même c'est quand même important
est ce que vous avez eu besoin d'être
gouvernementales durant les deux années
d'arrêt certainement comme comme
toujours l'entreprise jeudi qui inquiète
car où on a pu aurait pu conclure plus
bénéficient c'est à dire de cette
subvention amazon l'amazone est le
nouveau grand commanditaire en titre du
grand prix ça veut dire quoi de voir
amazon arrivée en france et un certain
justin entendre d'une seule année
c'est pour une seule année pour 2022 il
faut savoir qu amazon et c'est vraiment
une division d'amazon c'est au double
est ce
qui est déjà partenaire de la f1 depuis
2018 qui irait vite sur plusieurs
circuits dans le monde et comme on
n'avait pas de on n'avait pas dans le
fond de court a star nationale alors en
wrc un peu un peu dernière minute nous
approcher et donc ils seront dans le nom
de l'événement donc de l'événement
s'appelle le grand prix du canada au de
le virer il auront la visibilité
privilégie la ligne de départ mais c'est
pour une seule année je vais on était la
recherche et on eu plusieurs discussions
avec des partenaires nationaux et
comment va la recherche et le travail
sur le fait de devenir carboneutre c'est
quand même tout un défi pour la formule
1 le bilan carbone du grand prix est
estimé à 250 6000 tonnes de gaz à effet
de serre en 2019 comment on va arriver
carboneutre dans ce milieu
c'est vrai que c'est pour d'emblée
laissé pour ce professionnel et vise
évidemment disputant la formule 1 s'est
fixé comme objectif de cabourg note en
2030 alors nous avons également choisi
c'est l'objectif de travailler avec eux
il faut savoir déjà que depuis 2014 les
voitures sont à moteur hybride
les filles a dit aux équipes écouter à
partir de 2015 on va couper 30 % de
votre réservoir d'essence vous allez
devoir quand même parce que la distance
d'un grand prix 305 km vous avez d'abord
quand même trouver des façons de faire
305 clamait alors depuis ce temps là les
les vous savez en f1 les ingénieurs chez
mercedes et ferrari et red bull sont peu
près les meilleurs il existe et
aujourd'hui des équipes sont rendus
presque 50% de récupération d'énergie
pour faire un grand prix et les filles
ont passé bien que les voitures étaient
pourrait être plus lente ils sont plus
rapides aujourd'hui
il ya plusieurs années plusieurs étapes
qui au cours des prochaines années qui
vont nous amener en 2003 je vais être
obligé de vous re est invité pour parler
de cette question là qui est quand même
important lorsqu'on est temps pour le
faire jeudi monty merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir personne
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit